fabiano big victory for for you
congratulations but tell us a bit about
that monster preparation
uh well i played this line against sam
with the black pieces a few days ago
right and when he went for it so
confidently at the store he was playing
so quickly yesterday um
what i said yesterday
yesterday
it feels like a tournament already
[Laughter]
i could have sworn it was like a week
ago
we could have swore with you i think we
would have tested alongside you yeah so
yeah yesterday i played that game in sam
and when he went for this line i was so
worried
and he was thinking and thinking and i
the more he thought the less word i got
because i figured he wasn't really in
his preparation but i was thinking about
this move g5
and and this was something that you
figured out or found when you were
preparing from black's perspective
yeah yeah so
uh i was looking at this from the black
playing it from black point of view um
but it worried me so much and i realized
that
if i tried this move g5 with white
that it would most likely be very
unpleasant
for linear and i see like um the
computer shows a question mark for d5
which is we have a weak computer
don't pay attention but d5 is a
practical mistake i also thought it was
the most natural move um
but like the the best practical move is
queen to a5
wow
which
which basically equalizes on the spot
because white has to play bishop c4 bc4
uh queen d4
and black plays queen c5 and we get an
endgame or white has compensation which
is enough for the pawn but certainly no
more
um but i thought the chance of chance of
someone playing
uh queen to a5 it's a very unusual move
um
was low it's very low yeah i expected
either d5 or queen to c6 queen c6 is a
super fun move because it attacks the
rook and then prepares knight takes b2
uh knight takes v2 is also super fun i
don't know if you guys want to see these
lines but please i would love to see
them nice
v2 white plays queen to b3
queen boy three and here black has to
find queen to c6
attacking because the knight can't go to
c4 the queen's pin so the the queen has
to attack that rook on h1 so that if the
rook moves there's knight to c4
um and black saves the knight but here's
there's knight takes b5 and the only
move for black to survive is rook to a4
what that's natural
because you've never compared bishop to
b4
oh uh what's the threat yeah and queen
b2 bishop to b4
king d1 queen h1 king c2 it continues
to
wow like there's some shocking things
here like after king c2 if black plays
the natural move i think bishop to e7
it's a relatively natural move because
why is threatening king b3 winning a
piece
uh this totally loses after queen g7
rook of fate and rook to c1
rook c1 and this is dead loss for black
castling very important
uh so
so this
this is uh unlikely for black to survive
are you a netflix subscriber i mean this
is how you spent your time right
we're gonna get him
a kindle for his birthday
this is great stuff
wow
so i didn't think lanier would go for
this but anyway these were some fun
lines okay definitely queen c6 is
equally fun
it's a knight b2
and i think it's also very natural
because yes white has to move the rook
yes the best square is h4
right and now black has knight b2
yes and suddenly if queen b3 there's
rook to a3
so queen b3 is no longer a move or at
least it's not a move to play for an
advantage but white has queen to d4 here
and surprisingly black is on the verge
of losing knight c4 a4
it's a very random position um
and purely tactical black survives here
by a miracle again
um but
if you don't know the position your
chances of figuring this stuff out are
next to them yeah
knight b5 bishop b4
king to d1 and rook takes a4 and it's
it's eventually a draw
of course okay four queen before okay
king long short castle and uh
of course sure castle
well there's no it looks very dangerous
but there's no way to
attack that king because there's this
knight knight b2 resource bishop d3
knight b2
saves the game
so it's uh
so
we're sharpening the knives over here
yeah exactly we're we're going to need
you to join us in our commentary but wow
this is great fun
but i think what linear did was very
natural and also and also practical not
not bad at all yeah yeah
uh g5 he was surprised d5 was very nice
i don't think he expected a4 because
it's a bit
uh it's a bit of a bolt from a blue um
because it doesn't look like white
it can leave the b2 pawn hanging again
exactly um and the the positional point
well the whole positional point of g5 is
if black plays bishop b4 pretty much at
any moment
including here white plays bishop takes
c4 eliminating at night bc4
and bishop to e5 and we end up with this
position where
uh you have a nice glass yeah black
can't comfortably castle yeah the bishop
one e5 is
very firmly uh entrenched there yes and
it actually can't be removed for example
if king f8
which is the only decent move to defend
this pawn
white can make any number of moves but
if black ever plays bishop d6 queen d4
wins
so
uh there's there's no way to get rid of
that bishop yeah king f1 is the main
move and black has to
uh yeah play something besides bishop d6
because of the interbang so queen takes
d4 bishop takes d6s with a check
wow
so wow so i expected that he would go
for the end game because at least
it's probably not losing or anything um
i was kind of happy although i i didn't
think that he would ever go for but
queen to c6 instead of rook a4 is
is nearly immediately a draw
um
what rook a8
is only decent move
yeah it attacks that rook on h1 so queen
h1 king to d2
queen d1 is forced
king d1 and now an important move king
d7
much superior end game than what he got
in the game because what he got in the
game was a double pawn on the c file
well it's on c6 it's either losing on
the spot or it's a better version
because knight a4 might be winning but
after bishop d6 black survives
um
so b6 check king c7 or c6 yes
yes you lose a piece pardon me king c7
so
but it's very difficult to go for this
because you have to see bishop d6 in
advance it's quite quite far in advance
yeah and it looks it looks like you
might lose here by force so
so the practical approach was to take
play queens e6 like he did
um
and here he played an amazing move i
mean this was
um
this was great i i think k7 it's uh it's
the best move for sure
really yeah for sure
wow i'm pretty sure it's the best move
other movies king e2 rook a1 and i'm
invading very quickly
because i i think we were actually on
the bishop b7
uh 22 what did you think black could do
here
um
[Music]
what did we think we were going to do
okay
we were going to go somewhere in these
directions
yeah
to try to uh try to protect the bishop
but how like rook a7 king see at night
a4 i thought was winning ah
i think we wanted to put the king on c6
yeah yeah i was considering this maybe
king d7
sorry king d7 uh rookie one two three
one
uh okay one thing okay one king d7 but i
think i saw something strong after king
d7 maybe it was rook
maybe rook d1 is that possible
although that's a i was looking for some
like king c knight a4 stuff again yeah
um it might tactically work but it's
very difficult to go for this with black
because king c6 allows rook d8 you can't
do that
um king eight allows knight b5 most
likely and king c8 knight a4 it's it's
you know balancing on on a knife's edge
for him gotcha so what he did i think
was the the best choices
puts me in a tough position because now
i have to after bishop b7 i have to
decide between
a lot of very
attractive looking options but
none like stands out um if you don't
mind us asking the question
what are we still in your prep
no no i i just because you saw the move
king e7 you knew that that was the best
move
no no i i didn't i didn't analyze this
end game you know i apologize in any
real detail because
um i figured okay it's a safe it's a
safe you play for two results and right
this is pretty much the best case
scenario for the line where did he go
wrong
i think that he played well um i wasn't
happy to trade the bishops but i was
wondering if f6 was maybe a better
choice
um because
yeah he would love to trade those pawns
and like let's say gfgf
k4 and king d7 is quite important
and i was just going to play bishop c5
try to
press this position
but i assume that it's closer to a draw
than anything else but white still has a
rook g4 you know a lot of little probing
moves exactly
and then uh
so right back here as we get to the
crucial moments
uh coming up right here
you
felt that you've got to get the pawn to
keep the pressure up and how did you
evaluate your
chances around here well the position
should be a draw but i
thought he was very low on time and this
time control doesn't allow him to ever
get more time so i thought
i might have like a let's say thirty
percent chance of winning this position
i get you
and you were aware that he played a move
with one second i i understand i didn't
realize that oh you didn't it was
actually the losing move there we see it
on the screen the move ruggedly
hesitated the rook almost fell
he makes it
yeah
but i i figured i would win this
position because it's so so difficult
for black i didn't even see how he could
save it but
the engine
uh we didn't see how we could save it
but the engine does recommend eat rookie
one as black's best i was mainly
comparing bishop to d3 but rookie one
and wait if rookie one can i just start
pushing my g5 k5 g6
how is the
how is he defending this one does he
just start giving checks or
because my pawn is really fast oh king
king h7 allows rook g7 winning so king
h5 is forced exactly g6 and
wow
but your abs
fabi fantastic game just a simply
amazing game your perseverance paid off
uh you're now one game uh from winning
uh the champions bracket and
maybe your first two matches were a
little shaky but this looked really
really good our congratulations
fantastic stuff